i'll like sit on the edge of a on the
edge of a building and like take photos
and stuff but i will not bomb down a
hill in this game well yeah that sounds
really stupid almost as stupid as
[ __ ] with mike tyson on a flight
right okay so we're going to go back to
the 220 trends here since we did the
mike dyson bid uh chris wallace is now
trending and cnn plus is now trending um
this must be breaking news cnn plus oh
young service uh that was hi
cnn is actually cnn is reporting this i
don't know if you're if you're looking
at this but cnn is
[Laughter]
who wrote this at the company
one of the most significant developments
in the history of cnn get the [ __ ] out
of here with that [ __ ] cnn you really
are getting out on a ledge here this is
[ __ ] ridiculous we'll shut down on
april 30th did they even open up i don't
know they did they were open for two
weeks
oh oh so that's that's the extent of uh
yeah plus
this is one of those moments where you
play and i can't play because it'll get
uh flagged on on on youtube too but yeah
we'll have the youtube or the
the spongebob time card was like two
weeks later
[Laughter]
oh my god this is this is a great this
is this you know people are like oh the
mainstream media suck this is why they
suck right here like this this is cnn
why cnn sucks in one tweet
like okay cnn plus they think was the
most significant development in the
history of cnn and it lasted two weeks
you are a bunch of [ __ ] boneheads now
you heard you heard the netflix news
right netflix bomb yeah yeah they lost
like 30 or some [ __ ] right but
this is reid hastings believes that the
reason they lost money in the last
quarter was due to
uh password sharing he this is also
someone who was like you're talking
about netflix right right so reed
hastings is the ceo of netflix and
they've been developed trying to develop
technology where you can't password
share correct right right right they're
they're trying to they're yeah and i
think it's gonna piss off which is gonna
piss off subscribers right i mean i
think there was like a tip between hbo
uh go it was hbo go at the time uh which
is kind of like morphed into hbo max now
but it was hbo go in netflix and there
was reid hastings in the ceo of hbo and
he was like yeah [ __ ] i you know
anyone wants my password i'll give you
the password kind of thing and like i
think it was hbo was like poking
uh netflix to be like hey go [ __ ]
yourself
and uh he's like i don't care you know
but here's the thing they think that the
loss in revenue is due to uh people
sharing accounts and sharing passwords
right when in reality i don't know if
people know this but you know there's a
ton of money that they spend on original
content
acquiring content out of uh yeah they
like sundance or tribeca or whatever
they just buy the rights
or there's other things that they they
like well they bought they bought
seinfeld licensing that's right yeah
yeah you know they got friends they had
like office like these are things that
were purchased previously but i mean
netflix pays out millions
for um
for the right to have the content on the
platform exactly and and the the actors
on that show make bank every year one of
the one of the one of the things that
because it's been syndicated they're
like i don't have to work another day in
my life if i don't want to so
they they spend an absorbent amount of
money to push things because netflix
again is a numbers company they only run
on data if they're data driven they'll
say hey people really like uh
this type of genre and this type of show
we're looking for pitches on shows that
are like this or they'll saw hey people
at the company uh go out and find
content that matches these things we're
gonna have a bunch of dumb filler [ __ ]
that people are gonna watch we're gonna
have real meaty content with real good
actors we're gonna have stuff we're
gonna have documentaries we're gonna
have this we're gonna they just spend
money money money it's very much just
like you gotta spend you gotta burn
through cash to uh to develop this
growth at the company and however
as of late they're finding that it
actually isn't working out how they want
it right it's not as profitable as they
claim well and that's the problem here
is that they claim it's profitable but
when the numbers actually show that's
why they lost like i know almost 30
percent almost third of their value yeah
i don't know how many million i'm not
saying that netflix is the wework of uh
of like streaming i don't know what
wework is and that's probably what
you're getting at right so we work for
people who don't know and there's
actually there's a show right now
there's a there's a hulu documentary
about it uh there's a an apple tv show
that's called a we crashed
um
and uh it's all about the rise and fall
of wework now rework is still around
they went public through a merger but um
the the show itself
uh covers kind of
they spent an exorbitant amount of cash
to raise a ton of funding because their
belief was like if we expand and grow
that is what will lead to the proper
amount of uh success right and but what
they found out was they
were a little shady with their
accounting practices there's one
standard way that you would do your
financial kind of forms and um
transparency when you're going public
they decided to do their own thing where
they hid expenses so it all looked like
they were in the black and it was
positive um all these things are
revealed if you just google like we work
you'll find everything you need to know
but um it's another one of those things
where i'm not saying that netflix isn't
an actual sustainable model but they're
spending and burning cash to produce
content for people and in turn
that actual expansion and growth and
strategy isn't playing out how they want
it
well right well and and and when they
crashed uh at the end of the day
yesterday it actually pulled all these
streaming services down because what the
market said is oh well netflix the king
of streaming isn't worth what they say
and it isn't valued as high then maybe
these others aren't and maybe that's
where cnn really bit the bit the dust
here uh
kathy griffin has a great tweet here she
said so am i doing new year's eve on cnn
plus with chris wallace
of course in great fashion she makes a
fantastic joke um here about not only
cnn plus biting the dust but that their
flagship chris wallace i never really
understood this because the other day
they announced i didn't know that's what
he left for was seeing him plus right
chris wallace apparently is [ __ ]
infuriated that seeing in blessings
yeah i would be too if i agree well one
you know he was done with fox but if
you're promised like you're gonna have
the lead
lead show yeah the game but gabe was it
was it really cnn plus his plan
to get us to pay for cnn with i mean
chris wallace was supposed to make us
wanna yeah he was cnn yeah he was
talking out of here they were like
listen the only way people are
the only way we're gonna get cnn plus
is right chris wallace you're right
they're they're like hard hitting
the left the left the liberals they love
streaming they love anything plus so
we're gonna throw that on them and
they're gonna pay for it now the people
in the middle the people on the right as
well might be a little skeptical but
they're gonna see chris wallace and
they're gonna say uh we can bring him
over
and that's what the belief was right
there chris wallace you know he's the
he's the ace in the sleeve
for cnn plus yeah that's exactly what
was going on they shouldn't you know you
know i think i think they'll end up i i
don't know why they wouldn't give chris
wallace like cuomo's
time slot or something like that right
just put him on just put him on the cnn
that everyone would give acosta
the cuomo spot and give uh wallace the
acosta spot like there is many ways they
could have solved this i'm not saying
that a guy no one's going to watch it
anyways right it's right i'm also not
saying well here's the thing i also want
to donate like i don't you know think
that
i should take the role because whatever
i'm just saying like if you were trying
to pull in someone for a position why
not give them a coveted time slot you
know right right right well if they were
supposed to make people want to pay for
cnn then maybe they would get a time
slot there are some breaking news here
with the cnn thing um you know
number 24 scaramucci's
trending is trending um so everyone is
is lasted for one scare one
point
uh let's see claire has it here cnn uh
plus shutting down after a month and a
day or
no that's wrong is that yeah because
it's 11 days it's 11 days so that means
that this would be 22 this would almost
this would be more than a month this is
one month in one day but this is only
live for two weeks
well i don't know what is going on i
think people are doing the math wrong uh
well we we had scaramucci on and he
actually anthony go watch that episode
with anthony scaramucci um
we had anthony scaramucci on and he
confirmed boris that it is 11 days and
there's no better person than anthony
scaramucci to um
to make sure that you could clarify the
the
how long scaramucci said so that's the
breaking news on the cnn of how many
scaramucci's um some other
oh jesus this it's just a [ __ ] [ __ ]
show today